share once told me if it doesn't matter
in five years it doesn't matter and I
was like thank you share truer words god
I wish sherrod told me something
swapping no does it Tara
well is it it might not be the key but
it definitely helps I think learning how
to fight it for real
not like spar because I think humans
disagree a lot it's gonna happen you
can't there's no way to get around it
but if you learn how to have healthy
arguments I think it's the best thing
for a marriage my trick is I married
someone eight billion times nicer and
kinder and more patient and then some
reason he puts up with me and it's
worked out well
in truth I became much more comfortable
as I grew older and as you let go your
desire to compare yourself to everything
and everyone you realize how
unreasonable that is we are given once
you can really understand we are given
an unrealistic and unattainable idea and
representation of beauty you go oh wait
a minute
the whole thing is just a joke and a
trick oh then who cares
the worrying about what other people
think of you having become so so
unimportant also when you fill your life
with wonderful things and friends and
love you don't have taught you just
don't have time to worry about nonsense
find what makes you unique because if
you can be unique and be yourself you
are irreplaceable but the minute you
start to fall in line you're a dime a
dozen I remember when I was never
getting hired which was a good 20 or 22
years um and I thought maybe I'll go
into production and I'll stop the acting
side of it and I'll do this and I
remember my mom which I thought she was
gonna be thrilled with that much more
stable and she said bring you to get
back to doing what you do doesn't matter
your height doesn't matter what the
outcome is when you need to do what it
is you do so just kind of stay the
course if I say my husband no let's
start first of all I have Stockholm
Syndrome let's start it ha ha ha you
should be about eight years ago struga
she has done a great job of brainwashing
me and I'm telling you I am in ok
no I'm a big fan of my husband he's
funny he's kind he's committed to me and
our daughters and thousand other
wonderful things and he just makes me
smile now I have to say been too but I
mean it he's my faith my best friend and
he makes me laugh like gut laugh
starting to pass out I'm seeing sparkles
about four times a day and I don't know
I don't know anything that's better than
that I knew Dex before you that's true I
could have been mrs. Dex we don't know
it was never offered I don't even want
to know if you guys hooked up yes I
don't like I don't when hello oceans in
mine I wouldn't put it past either of
you and that's fine little gorgeous it
without you weird if right now I'm like
by the way we dated for six months I
wanted to jump on the deal